Google has taken an extremely
sophisticated approach when it comes to
Adblock given that they're an ad
business it would have been easy for
them to complain and try to eliminate
all remnants of Adblock but instead it
they've looked to structure ad block in
a way that benefits them they've used
that block to protect their market share
simultaneously they've also worked with
Adblock to whitelist ads on most of
their core Services other than desktop
YouTube the bottom line is that Google
understands that eliminating Adblock is
not the solution the solution is to make
the ad experience so good that people
don't even feel the need to use Adblock
even if it's available